[Music]
second day of national railway strikes
is underway after talks between the rmt
union and employers ended in deadlock
the dispute centers on pay working
conditions and job security around four
out of five services will not run today
we're told and people are being advised
to work from home if you possibly can
let's hear from fraser who is in chester
dan standing by at bristol temple mead
station for us this morning um dan first
of all
tell us what's happening
morning okay well you can see the picket
line is in place outside bristol temple
mead station already this morning uh the
figure of the number of trains running
here reflects that national image eighty
percent of uh services cancelled here at
temple means this is of course the major
junction for trains in the south west uh
you change here to go west to wales
north up to birmingham south down to
devon and of course to london there are
a limited number of services running
here uh five services some to london
some to cardiff some to taunton and
plymouth in devon and westbury in
wiltshire uh but the figures that we've
just been handed in the last couple of
minutes show that football
on tuesday strike was uh
down by 70
so a real impact clearly here at the
station as many people are having to
work from home there's no rail
replacement as such so people having to
make alternative arrangements
glastonbury started yesterday as we all
saw many people struggling to get down
to the festival there there may be a few
latecomers trying to get their way down
to the festival here but as i say the
furthest south you can get from bristol
today is plymouth in devon right on the
cornish border for absolutely no trains
at all running in cornwall throughout
these strike days that whole county
completely cut off people having to make
alternative arrangements we are
expecting a few people to start rocking
up for those early services
running here at bristol temple meads but
you can see the workers behind me here
getting plenty of honks and support from
drivers going past here as the second
day of strikes gets underway
um
thank you fraser uh morning to you as
well situation there
morning k well no picket lines here at
chester railway station but no
passengers either down there mentioning
a 20
service that's uh operating from bristol
and the 20 figure that we keep hearing
about
the level of trains available is country
wide it's not in places like chester
smaller places like this that rely on
more local services rather than on the
mainline networks uh are closed all
together and that's been a real problem
uh for many of the for many of the
traders here we'll be talking later on
this morning to one store owner who's
saying that it's created a massive drop
in business and they are bracing
themselves for saturday normally their
busiest day and the day of the third
planned uh strike action so it's
unlikely that the talks are going to
wrap up quickly enough in order to
prevent any strike action on on saturday
we were hearing um yesterday that uh if
an agreement had been made yesterday
during the talks that that was going to
be too late to prevent strike action
today because timetables and so on we're
already
in place and that looks as though it's
going to be the case for saturday as
well and i think a lot of places that
rely on rail services that are now
effectively cut off during these days of
rail strikes will be looking pretty
nervously towards the summer and in the
hope that this situation can be resolved
before further strikes are called for
later on in the summer people have been
able to find alternatives i know the
department for transport was saying
yesterday that the strike hadn't had the
impacts that maybe the unions had been
hoping for but
an impact in terms of people finding
alternatives is still an impact there
are still tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of people who've had to change
their plans during these uh during the
strike days and during the other days
this week when there's been disruptions
which have been caused by the knock-on
effects of the strike days so saying
that there's no impact uh whatsoever or
reduced impact i think is is perhaps not
necessarily the case people have been
trying to find alternatives we have got
used to working from home and lots of
people have been doing that and they
down there mentioned that some of the
figures in terms of football in football
in places like bristol are down but
there have been reports that some of the
data suggesting that football in smaller
market towns and so on has actually gone
up as a result of people working from
home and going into the local town
centre to buy their cups of coffee or to
have lunch or whatever so football in
some instances has increased slightly
only slightly and only in in small
market towns as a result of the strike
action but i think what's interesting is
throughout the uh throughout the whole
uh timeline of this uh event from the
initial vote that had taken place by uh
the rmt members uh to to go for strike
action and then the announcement of the
dates of the strike action uh and now
that the strikes have actually started
the commuters and passengers that i've
been speaking to still broadly support
the strike action saying that if that's
what they need to do in order to get a
reasonable reasonable wage then that's
what they need to do okay gentlemen
thanks for the update much appreciated
we will keep you updated of course uh
throughout the course of the morning
here on sky news a little more detail as
we enter the second day of strike action
here we go services across england
scotland and wales are affected people
being asked to work from home where
possible
15 separate train companies say they
will run a limited service today with
lines closing earlier than normal
all lner trains for example will depart
before 4 pm
here are the other companies running
fewer trains southeastern railway and
the newly opened elizabeth line are just
two of them
elsewhere trans-pennine express and
northern rail have warned of significant
disruption and mersey rail will have no
trains or replacement bus services
in scotland no trains will run north of
the glasgow to edinburgh route and
nearly all services in wales will stop
with a very limited service in south
wales
for the latest travel updates throughout
the day visit the national rail website
and also sky news website
in other news the taliban has appealed
for international aid after an
earthquake killed more than a thousand
people in the east of afghanistan many
international aid agencies pulled out of
the country after the taliban takeover
and the country's economy is in a state
of collapse joined now from kabul by
becky roby from the norwegian refugee
council one of the few international
agencies still operating in the country
hi becky thank you for joining us what
is the latest situation as you are aware
of it
well this looks set to be one of the one
of the worst earthquakes that
afghanistan has experienced in in
decades thousands of homes have been
lost thousands of lives have been lost
um and many people have been seriously
injured the level of destruction is
likely to be far higher than the numbers
that we currently have due to the
mountainous nature of um some of the
areas that have been impacted
um the focus for the norwegian refugee
council at the moment is to be providing
humanitarian support to families that
have been displaced who have lost their
homes
and we have teams on the ground
yesterday and today who are doing
assessments and preparing to provide
emergency cash support and shelter
support in the form of tents
we hope to provide support to families
in the long run to find some sort of
longer-term solution for their
displacement and this is something
that's been very challenging um
long-term solutions in general in
afghanistan since
a lot of the development assistance to
afghanistan has
has reduced and we've seen an enormous
economic collapse in the country due to
financial restrictions that have been
placed um on afghanistan um millions of
afghanistans are currently living on the
edge of survival have spent their
savings and sold their belongings over
the winter just to survive and this
makes them incredibly vulnerable to
shocks like earthquakes or droughts or
flooding and ultimately what we want to
do is to reduce people's vulnerability
to these sorts of shocks and to do that
we need a functioning economy in
afghanistan we need a functioning estate
and we need development assistance
how well equipped are afghan emergency
services to respond to
an incident such as this
the the taliban authorities have been
leading their response the humanitarian
response so far conducting search and
rescue operations um in the country but
their resources are limited um
they're they're doing the best they can
with the resources that they have and
humanitarian aid agencies like the
norwegian refugee council are doing our
best to provide support to that but it
is very challenging in these
circumstances
we know that at least a thousand people
have died potentially that figure could
climb significantly as more aid workers
arrive
what can outside aid agencies do to help
outside aid agencies in the short run
and there should be funding made
available for the humanitarian response
to meet the immediate needs of
people affected by this conflict and
by the earthquake but in the long run we
we need longer term solutions for
afghanistan um so we need that
development assistance and we need a
functioning economy in the country
at governmental level you need the
british government and other governments
around the world to get involved
all right um
that's uh we'll leave that up to the
governments to decide how they want to
respond to the crisis um but emergency
humanitarian support and would be very
welcome right now
um oh
what about um the situation you touched
on there as far as the drought
and the starvation is concerned and of
course um while we are in the relatively
warmer weather at the moment you say
what's been happening over the last uh
few months indeed since last august when
the brits
and americans and other countries pulled
out
ngos over the last year have been
humanitarian ngos have been incredibly
stretched um
we we feel like we've been um you know
keeping off an emergency keeping off a
catastrophe
and that's been possible due to
finances that were made available for
this emergency humanitarian response but
it's not something that can continue um
there needs to be development assistance
and the economy needs to be kicked back
into action
and what we really need is to change the
narrative towards ngos towards
afghanistan at the moment um we don't
want ngos to be
helping afghans survive we want to be
putting afghans in a position to thrive
and at the moment we're not in a
position to do that we know that next
year funding is probably going to
decline for afghanistan there's a lot of
competition at the moment particularly
with the ukraine crisis with somalia
with yemen and so we need better options
in the long run for the country
and some concern
that
western countries may not want to
help support a country that's run by the
taliban i suppose
there's a there's a huge amount of
hesitancy to do anything that may
inadvertently legitimize the taliban
government and that's also something
that's been challenging for ngos who
have remained in the country providing
essential services
that we are concerned about possible
risks um for example under the sanctions
to us and but i think what we want to be
drawing attention to now is the impacts
on afghan people of this political
isolation
of the country um we've managed to
hold off a crisis hold off an emergency
in the country so far this year and but
what will happen next year as you
mentioned with the winter coming uh it's
um
it's quite uncomfortable to think about
that yeah um
becky a great job that you do thanks for
taking the time to join us this morning
much appreciated
thank you very much thank you
quick look at papers for you this
morning metro leads with the news about
polio nationwide polio alert is the
headline there also leading the daily
mail which says health chiefs fear it
might be spreading in the uk
the eye paper also has that story on its
cover with the headline polio found in
britain for the first time in 40 years
and so does the times which features the
nhs campaign to ensure children are
vaccinated against the virus let's talk
about it in more detail should we dr uh
devi sridhar is with us now professor in
global public health at the university
of edinburgh hi doctor thanks for
joining us how concerned are we
well i think obviously it is concerning
polio is a disease that we've tried to
eradicate in all parts of the world we
had remaining cases in afghanistan
pakistan nigeria and to see it here in
london it's obviously a worry but on the
flip side we have a vaccine it's part of
the routine childhood vaccination
program so if any parents are there are
watching if your child has gotten their
usual nhs vaccine appointments and make
those then they will be protected from
polio
the concern is that potentially um
children have not had this not all
children have had their second doses
when would a child
routinely have a second dose
well you have right now polio vaccine
split into kind of four parts and that's
given at various ages who are younger
and right now they're not sure how far
the extent is in london they think it
might be a small cluster perhaps an
extended family this was found through
sewage which is kind of routinely tested
for polio as part of the global polio
eradication initiative and so what they
might do is bring it forward so rather
having it six months or a year two years
it actually perhaps they need to
accelerate it but i would say right now
right now it still looks quite small in
terms of the cluster that's there it's
not widespread community transmission
and also i know people think covid they
think restrictions they think public
health that's not core public health
core public health is actually right now
about finding those cases trying to
identify individuals having them isolate
and use vaccination and other kind of
mechanisms to try to manage this problem
how could this have happened doctor
well it looks like in other parts of the
world they use oral polio vaccine which
is a live vaccine and it's likely that
that someone has come into the country
with that has spread it to others we
know through a live vaccine that
actually can spread to others the one we
use in britain is not live it's actually
an inactive vaccine and so what you
found then is that this is probably
spread a bit it's mutated into a
different form and now they've picked it
up over several weeks of testing sewage
and therefore that's why they are saying
well actually there is transmission
occurring based on looking at the
sequencing of the strain that they're
picking up um polio circulating in other
parts of the world it's research because
of covid kind of we're seeing that with
measles other diseases and so
unfortunately for the public health
teams adding to covid adding to monkey
parks they now have to deal with
polio as well and trying to chase down
those cases i'm intrigued to know why we
would have been tested it was it was
detected into sewage works why would we
be um trying to track it um if it's we
thought it was obsolete in this country
for the best part of 40 years
well it was declared eliminated in
britain in 2003 and since then as part
of the global efforts most countries
that can are trying to test their sewage
it's a great way instead of having you
know daily testing in different
individuals to actually do at a
population level just routinely test
wastewater we're now doing this for
covet 19 to check actually is there
anything out there and then to pick it
up quickly so this surveillance is in
place and that's absolutely brilliant
because otherwise we wouldn't know if we
didn't we weren't testing sewage and
actually looking at what is happening so
it's part of the global effort and the
uk's commitment to that to actually say
we tried to retain our status of having
it eliminated and pick it up very very
early using wastewater sewage and then
move quickly to try to make sure there's
widespread vaccination but also look at
exactly where that was in london and try
to find those cases and make sure it
doesn't spread further
and just to clarify as far as adults are
concerned if they've not had
vaccinations um what do they do
they should be reaching out to their gp
if you are in london if you are
concerned um if you also feel you might
be particularly at risk then you can
also get a booster there is a booster
offered after about 10 years and so i
think um right now there's not yet an
impetus for a widespread
mass vaccination campaign it'll be
really targeted right now to children
who are unprotected um it's very similar
i think to monkey pox in the sense of
actually targeting vaccination who needs
it most before you go for a widespread
campaign but it is a reminder that if
you are unvaccinated and you feel like a
false sense of security these diseases
aren't circulating lumps also you know
um pertussis measles these are all
coming back and they are
unfortunately finding people who are
unvaccinated and making them unwell
um if you have the vaccination um does
that make you unwell for a little while
i'm sure that's what one of the
questions will be to people who go to
the gp
actually even better if you are fully
vaccinated you are protected from
infection and with all the doses it's 99
to 100 infected and you likely cannot
get polio or transmitted so actually
that's how we've managed to also not
have it around and eliminate it in most
countries of the world it really is a
large step backward in global health
again we were chasing down one point
there were only 30 cases in the entire
world in you know conflict written areas
or extremely poor areas um so it's a
step backwards but again we've got to be
on our front foot in public health and
try to chase down those cases
and alert people to what's happening and
so they can also make sure they protect
themselves and their families
great to talk to you doctor thank you
very much indeed for clarifying thank
you
thank you
don't forget no government minister or
uh shadow minister today because there
are two by-elections taking place one in
tibetan in devon and one in wakefield up
in the north behind the red wall there
um we will of course cover those for you
from 10 o'clock this evening and then i
will reflect on the results as they come
in tomorrow morning on the breakfast
show
coming this morning though did trump's
team try to sway the election result
lawyer and activist dr scholler and
political commentators scotty
they're quite a double act aren't they
both joining us um a little bit later on
with just one in five trains running
today and continued chaos at our
airports we'll be speaking to a familiar
face on the programme simon colder later
in the hour
[Applause]
and getting legendary england spin bowl
and monty panason's reaction to
international cricket returning to
headingley today
before that looking at some of today's
other stories making headlines for you
ukraine looks set to be given eu
candidates status at today's summit in
brussels that's the first formal step
towards membership of the european union
ukraine applied to join the block days
after the russian invasion
europe's future is bright and free
because we all stand together to protect
it
i'm grateful to all those who support us
thank you for this sincerity amsterdam
looking forward to a positive european
decision for ukraine
u.s prosecutors say that gillane maxwell
should spend 30 to 55 years in jail the
60 year old socialite was convicted of
engaging in a sex trafficking scheme
with her former partner jeffrey epstein
maxwell's lawyers have argued she
deserves less than the 20-year term
that's actually been recommended she'll
receive her sentence in new york next
week man in charge of the police
response to last month's school shooting
in uvalde in texas has been put on leave
pete arredon pete arredondo forgive me
has been accused of abject failure over
his decisions after it emerged police
waited for a key to an unlocked
classroom door while the shooter was
still at large
u.s president joe biden has called for
the suspension of federal gas and diesel
taxes for three months in a bid to give
families a little bit of relief from
record prices prices in the u.s average
about five dollars a gallon that's about
half the cost of filling up your car
here in the uk
eight people including doctors and
nurses who cared for the football legend
diego maradona will be tried for
homicide in argentina maradona died
after suffering a cardiac arrest in 2020
they're accused of acting in an
inappropriate deficient and reckless
manner no date for the trial has yet
been set
day two of glastonbury with more than
two hundred thousand revelers expected
to descend on worthy farm across the
weekend so before we head there
ourselves let's take a quick listen to
some of the acts playing over the next
few days
[Music]
is
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen from new zealand
there you go
fabulous um arts and entertainment
correspondent katie spencer is standing
by of course she knew who everybody was
didn't you morning casey
yeah my cameraman's enjoying himself he
was having a little dance i just wish we
could turn the camera around but the
camera around but sadly you can't at
this time of day um yeah music the main
music will get underway of course
tomorrow friday is the big day when the
big acts come into town and start
playing these this time in between is
really when uh you get to explore the
site you get to wander into this sort of
strange weird areas and come across
unusual dj sets go and hang out with the
sort of jugglers and the circuses and
things like that and so it's more about
exploring at the moment sort of enjoying
the weirdness of worthy farm the big
music is coming tomorrow but before that
of course
everyone here is having to to face the
fact that we've had this met office
warning that torrential downpours are on
the way this glorious wall-to-wall
sunshine that we've been having
over the last couple of days is due to
be replaced by the rain that means
umbrellas the uh the wellies as well are
going to be coming out and of course
that as well means strategically where
you've placed your your tent will really
sort of come into its own you definitely
want to be at the top of the hill rather
than the bottom of the hill where all
the rain water ends up yeah the met
office as well uh channeling their inner
bob dylan saying that people may need to
be sheltering from the storm so it could
be around lunchtime that this all
looks very different around here but
yeah we are one of the few that are up
at this time we actually should be
talking a bit more quietly because
people are still sleeping as we speak
but yeah it's a hardy few uh out and
about we should just point out very very
sweetly behind us uh this lady's got up
especially to for her friend ellie to
put out the happy birthday bunting
people making a real effort enjoying the
sunshine uh really making the most of
their time and of course
the weather's going to change so we need
to be sitting out now really enjoying
the sunshine while we can because i
suspect glastonbury in the coming days
with this rain it's expected isn't going
to be as easy to sit out and enjoy the
sunshine certainly um do you actually
sleep in a tent while you're there
covering this story for us
i absolutely do okay can you not tell by
uh the uh slightly unkempt hair that i'm
sporting today so yeah i hope you'll
join in when you're fabulous as always
um another couple of questions if i may
how much does it cost for a ticket i'm
guessing they're all sold out and just
in case people weren't with us yesterday
who are the headliners
well 280 pounds uh for a ticket if you
managed to get hold of one of course uh
when they all went on sale back in uh
2019 pre-pandemic of course life has
radically changed since then i think
cost of living a lot of people who are
actually here now perhaps wouldn't have
been able to fork out that level of
money again it is one of the the more
expensive tickets to get your hands on
but it is the golden ticket because
you've got such a good lineup of
performers certainly this year as well
friday you've got the youngest solo
artist to headline glastonbury billy
eilish is going to be taken to the stage
on a saturday you've got to paul
mccartney he of course is one of the
oldest headline acts as well turned 80
just last week but of course what a show
he's got a two and a quarter hour set
he's going to obviously do many of the
hits people are really going to enjoy
that one sunday kendrick lamar described
my many as one of the greatest rappers
of the 21st century so really something
for everyone's taste but um one of the
joys of glastonbury is if you're not
into things that are happening on the
main stage you go you explore you
discover new music it's a lot of fun
okay you need to be here hey fantastic
and you look amazing katie saying you're
living in a tent my goodness you look
gorgeous thanks very much indeed for
updating us thank you
well glass debris has had its fair share
of superstars but there's one man
they've never been able to get hold of
you might have heard of him his name is
sir elton john and this weekend he's
performing at the first british
summertime festival in hyde park for
three years
along with islam
[Music]
one of the questions is who's going to
be drumming for them uh the rolling
stones um celebrating their 60th
anniversary this year with a headline
performance in hyde park on saturday the
festival has been cancelled for the last
two years due to kovid and the virus
threatened to derail it again this year
when mick jagger announced that he
tested positive last week but he's been
given the all clear to hit the stage and
just last night the stones packed out
milan's famous san siro stadium
yes they did
now final test match between england and
new zealand today at headingley will be
the first time yorkshire has hosted
international cricket since it was
suspended by the english cricket board
because of allegations of racism let's
get the latest now from james cole who's
standing by for us sky sports of course
hi first time that they have hosted this
since all of that ferrari previously at
headingley an exciting day i'm guessing
for them
yeah you'd think so wouldn't you okay
exciting day a day they want to mark but
we've not actually heard from anyone in
senior management at the club this week
to mark the return of international
qriket here which is interesting and
surprising because eight months ago this
club looked like it may go under as you
say the ecb withdrew its right to host
international cricket in order to bring
through the reform the changes it felt
was needed hitting yorkshire in the
pocket if you like in order to force
change change happened a new chairman
came in in lord patel he sacked 16
members of staff but i suspect the
reason we're not hearing much from
yorkshire this week is because the
wranglings off the field are still
ongoing just last week six of those
staff won the first stage of their
employment tribunal for wrongful
dismissal meanwhile their 2020 captain
david willey
left the club citing uh disappointment
in the fact that yorkshire are more
interested in looking after their
reputation than their players and
meanwhile former board members are now
criticizing lord patel for the way in
which he swept through those changes too
rapidly too quickly so yes this is a
very significant day it's a great day
for yorkshire cricket club bringing
international cricket back is so
important as a stadium that's hosted so
many amazing amazing moments in qriket's
history but there's a real divide
between what's happening on the field
and the discontent off the field at a
club that is now very much divided more
on one of our top stories for you this
morning rescue operations continue in
afghanistan after a powerful earthquake
in the east of the country killed at
least a thousand people yesterday
well this looks set to be one of the one
of the worst earthquakes that
afghanistan has experienced in in
decades thousands of homes have been
lost thousands of lives have been lost
we hope to provide support to families
in the long run to find some sort of
longer-term solution for their
displacement and this is something
that's been very challenging um
long-term solutions in general in
afghanistan since um a lot of the
development assistance to afghanistan
has with has reduced and we've seen an
enormous economic collapse in the
country due to financial restrictions
that have been placed um on afghanistan
um millions of afghanistans are
currently living on the edge of survival
have spent their savings and sold their
belongings over the winter just to
survive and this makes them incredibly
vulnerable to shocks like earthquakes or
droughts or flooding
well joining us now from islamabad in
pakistan is our correspondent to inzamam
rashid
hi good to see you this morning um talk
to us about the situation there and what
if anything pakistan can do to help
morning k look as you heard there this
is a catastrophic
destruction that has occurred in east
afghanistan it's really crushed a lot of
homes a lot of livelihoods
and indeed killed over a thousand people
that death toll is expected to rise
overnight through the night
locals were digging through the rubble
to find any signs of survival any uh
bodies that remain under the rubble and
that continued when light struck around
five o'clock this morning but what's
incredibly difficult and will be over
the next 48 hours is the weather there
is expected to be storms and heavy rain
which will of course
will encourage landslides in the area
and floods which will have a huge
knock-on effect and could see the damage
get even worse in terms of international
aid it's something that the taliban are
pleading for of course the taliban
someone which the world has pretty much
abandoned over the last year because of
the takeover of afghanistan last year
but they are pleading for international
help neighbouring countries pakistan and
iran have supported iran this morning
sending two plane loads of aid pakistan
sending around eight truckloads over the
border to the site of the disaster and
qatar as well sending a plane load of
aid into kabul the big question will be
is if these international
organizations and countries send aid
into the capital car ball it'll be very
difficult to get it up to the remote
regions where the earthquake has struck
and that will be a huge challenge for
the taliban the unsa that they simply
don't have the infrastructure in place
to deal with such a seismic natural
disaster so a huge worry ahead not only
because of the weather on the horizon
but also this rescue operation which is
proving incredibly difficult for an
organization which has mainly been
abandoned by a lot of the world over the
last year okay insane thank you very
much indeed thank you
no politics today but big issues as far
as polio is concerned that's right polio
you might have thought it was consigned
to the history books at least here in
the uk we haven't had a case contracted
here in the uk since the early 1980s but
now
scientists at the uk health security
agency are concerned that they have
found
sewage samples in london which suggest
that there is polio circulating and they
are urging anyone whose child has not
been vaccinated or who has not been
vaccinated themselves to go and get
vaccinated to prevent this causing a
wider outbreak because of course um the
uk was declared polio free about two
decades ago but the concern is that
although most people in london and
indeed the uk are fully protected
against it because they have been
vaccinated in childhood and there is
concern that in areas some areas of
london where vaccination rates are a bit
lower than average that this could start
spreading and so there's just an alert
out there because polio is for many
people
a mild illness but it can in severe
cases cause
paralysis or even death and so um we've
been hearing from the professor devi
schroder of edinburgh university and she
told us how concerning this is
obviously it is concerning polio is a
disease that we've tried to eradicate in
all parts of the world we had remaining
cases in afghanistan pakistan nigeria
and to see it here in london it's
obviously a worry but on the flip side
we have a vaccine it's part of the
routine childhood vaccination program so
if any parents are there are watching if
your child has gotten their usual nhs
vaccine appointments and make those then
they will be protected from polio
and the reason we're not talking
politics today because there are two
by-elections today one of them in
wakefield in west yorkshire the other
one in tibetan and huntington in devon
so people in those two areas will be
able to vote the mps the seats are
currently held by the conservatives and
facing challenges from other parties and
we obviously can't tell you any more
because the by-election rules but people
voting in those two areas and we will
get the results uh probably the early
hours of the morning tomorrow and bring
you everything as soon as we get it yeah
be busy morning tomorrow tomorrow
morning won't it thanks tomorrow for now
thank you
um we will of course have full coverage
on sky news uh from
midnight tonight uh the results uh as i
said in fact as tomorrow just said on
the breakfast show from seven o'clock in
the morning two by-elections
that are being held
today
well election officials in the united
states have been giving moving testimony
to the january 6 committee about the
pressure they faced following the 2019
election violent threats from trump
supporters and requests to find 11 000
votes were among some of what they
endured what do dr scholler and scotty
think of that i'm sure though neither of
them will be holding back with their
views uh good morning both let's start
with you scotty if i may um
would an indictment of donald trump
based on the new evidence from the
hearings be
feasible likely
reasonable
well good morning and once again i like
almost every single republican k
absolutely condemn the actions that
happened on j6 that was violent and any
illegal actions that happened by the
people there or the encouragement and i
do agree that we do as americans that
need to investigate to find out what
those were however to look at this
circus that is going on right now in the
hill as anything other than a partisan
fishing expedition to sow deceit and to
distract from the real issues that are
facing america right now because of the
biden agenda is completely naive and
turning a blind eye to the reality of
what is going on there are certain
things that this committee refused to
ask now i agree you should look into if
there was those pressures however is it
worth the time and the devotion that is
being put into this when there are so
many pressing issues and it's not what
necessarily they're looking into k that
is making this look very bipartisan and
very partisan it's actually what they're
ignoring the fact that they're ignoring
why capital police actually moved
barricade that's not coming up why the
national guard that trump asked request
was denied by nancy pelosi they're not
even looking at that the select
committee of republicans put on there
from the very beginning this was seen to
be a very partisan fishing expedition
hoping to come up with something and at
this point if there was any sort of real
illegal activity that was committed by
those with the trump campaign you can
guarantee merrick garland and the
democrats would already have them in
jail just like they have those that were
involved that day still sitting in jail
not being prosecuted almost a year and a
half later dr childer
oh lord scotty what a contradiction on
one hand you condemn the january 6
violence and on the other hand you are
challenging those who want to bring
justice and hold people to account i
mean you need to make up your mind
because you sound inconsistent the
bottom line is that so far this generous
experience have demonstrated to us how
you know the depth and breadth of
trump's pressure on local and state
officials how widespread it was to the
extent that the lives of election
workers was at risk i mean look at the
testimony of sheamus it's just
devastating and you also have to
understand that there's generally six
hearings what you're doing is holding
people to account and all the questions
they're asking are the right ones the
pressure was wrong trump has committed a
crime
we are now dealing with an america where
facts don't matter and america whose
democracy is fragile an america that is
revered around the world as a model of
democracy but was nearly brought down to
its knees by the corruption and lack of
integrity of its highest office so how
can you sit there and go no yeah i
condemn the violence but no we this is
just a fishing expedition we shouldn't
do anything about it this is necessary
this is necessary not just for history
it's necessary for the future so that
this never happens again and that's the
point the 2020 elections were not
overturned there was no electoral fraud
and this hearings are showing that
donald trump and his allies never had
any evidence whatsoever to prove there
was an electoral electoral fraud donald
trump was simply trying to overturn the
2020 elections for his own private gain
and he used members of congress to
achieve this
um ladies i just wanted to ask you um
about a tweet that i'm looking at from
marjorie taylor green we all know who
she is of course um and she's tweeted to
say when british press wants to argue
about our god-given american gun rights
my answer is go back to your own country
i wonder if you'd like to pick that one
up scotty
well that's almost a completely you know
obviously marger taylor green i'll be
the last person to try to explain some
of her reactions and especially right
now these are the issues that we are
addressing here in the united states
that democrats don't want to do hence
why they do want to distract i mean we
just had a horrible school shooting and
we're proposing gun legislation here in
the united states that should be the
focus because that's actually affecting
americans but to say that the focus is
on the january 6 committee that that's
going to have any effect and that if a
crime was committed i guarantee it would
have already been prosecuted a year and
a half and trump would be in jail for it
because guess what biden and his doj
have done that but they continue to hide
14 000 hours of j6 video that happened
from the capitol that day they continued
to hide they had put no mention about
the actual death that happened on
capitol hill of ashley of ashley babbitt
this is all a partisan to distract from
the real issues when in reality if
democrats actually had some real um
heart they had some real belief in their
agenda that's what they would be
focusing on on instead of this
distraction which by the way is only
hurting their continued chances and if
they really cared about the safety of
americans they would ask when they would
ask the doj to investigate who exactly
laid the pipe bombs in front of the army
and
i respond we only have a limited time on
tv
can can i respond can i respond thank
you very much thank you scotty um i
think the entire world watching this the
viewers can see how you oh distracted
from the question that was posed to you
about gun rights and can i just answer
that that the answer to the gun rights
and the gun control bill has been on
there but the republicans have been the
ones stopping it because they're in bed
with the nra let me just put that out
there the other point you're just
raising again about the january 6
hearings all this talk about the capital
police all of that can be looked about
why can you not say that trump and the
members of congress
republicans should be held to account
and why can't you talk about the
devastating results and you know what
the testimonies that we're hearing why
can't you speak to that and that to me
tells me that as far as i'm concerned
you're in agreement with this because
the republican party has become the
party of apologists and that's what you
sound like right now like an apologist
it has become the party of
insurrectionists and this is wrong no
matter how much you want to bring up the
capitol police we can go through every
single point how long it took trump to
to call out for any kind of assistance
because it took him a long time but the
bottom line here is the rut stats from
the top and that top at that time was
donald trump and he had to be held to
account
scotty
well the thing is it's not about
accountability we believe in
accountability the republican party is
that's the problem with this if you want
true accountability it's all about one
side if you wanted true accountability
if that's what the democrats were
seeking then they would have allowed the
republicans to actually go in and put
who they went on the committee instead
it was a very select liz cheney adam
kissinger it was a very weak and that
was the whole point from the very
beginning this was going to be a fishing
expedition and once again the doj has
done all of this research and yet they
cannot find the simple answers so he put
the pipe bombs in front of the two
largest political parties in the united
states
hold on ladies ladies ladies thank you
you've had your go uh dr scholler let
scotty speak and then you can respond as
a result scotty away you go
so once again if trump had actually
committed crimes and once again what was
the crime that he committed you know
sherlock keeps saying oh he committed a
crime what was that exact crime and if
you know of this crime can you tell it
to the attorney general can you tell it
to congress because they have yet to
find the evidence to charge him with a
single thing so maybe you're smarter and
i assume you are than all of congress
that is putting on this multi-million
dollar charade but at this point there
hasn't been a crime there hasn't been an
arrest
and it looks like there won't be one
despite just a major pr campaign
study well it appears that you suffer
from selective amnesia so please let me
help you out when you say the
republicans were not part of this they
were invited they rejected it mitch
mcconnell rejected people and actually
he did not allow other republicans to
take part those who did take part have
been treated like you know pariahs so
don't don't make it sound like the
republican party we're not invited to be
part of this process they weren't and
the way you asked me a question like
what did trump do
two years after the fact after
everything we've all seen i mean i
mentioned the fact that we all know that
he called state you know law makers that
he met with them he made threatening
phone calls he was asking for eleven
principles he is not meant to do that
that is corruption that is corruption
study how is that not obvious and look
and maybe yes the general six hearings
are going through the process to gather
all of the evidence to make it as
transparent as possible but in 2022 my
dear scotty you cannot be asking me the
question or anybody else the question
what did trump do wrong he did plenty
wrong he did everything wrong and the
entire world and its grandmother can see
that
but obviously they can't maybe the
entire world can according to you but
the attorney general can't the
department of justice can't and even the
democrats can't because they cannot
build up enough case to justify the
arrest and prosecution of donald trump
even a year and a half later supposedly
with all of this evidence you might not
agree with what he did i don't agree
with everything but that doesn't make it
illegal big difference
no it does make it illegal this is part
of the process it's part of the process
asking the questions speaking to
witnesses gathering the evidence that is
part of the process so maybe you
shouldn't jump that hoop yet let's see
how it goes well
later when everything is so public if
the hoop's already been jumped through
the hoop's been thrown out the window
this is all about making sure that trump
does not run in 2024 and demonizing this
is a really a hail mary's chance of the
democrats to try to salvage whatever
they think they're going to be able to
handle in november and demonize the
republicans and hopefully demonize
anybody that would dare identify them
okay we started with you scotty so we
must finish with dr very quickly 30
seconds if you would all right the fact
that there's a hell chance of the
republican party having donald trump as
its 2024 candidate says all day has to
be said about the republican party
absolutely pits that's exactly where the
republican party is right now because
donald trump should have no chance
whatsoever being in the public office
ever again
ladies it's great to have you back uh
we've missed you come back soon thank
you very much indeed thank you
now as we've been reporting it's the
final test match between england and new
zealand today at headingley it'll be the
first time that yorkshire has hosted
international cricket since it was
suspended by the english cricket board
because of allegations of racism joining
us now former england cricketer monty
panissar hi monty great to see you
thanks for joining us let's talk about
the game uh first of all for people who
haven't been following the previous
matches where are we
well thank you for having me on the show
yeah it's been absolutely brilliant you
know turned around by past mcallen and
you know ben stokes and in the space of
two weeks they've kind of changed the
fortunes you know of english cricket
they've won two test matches where in
the last 17 we only managed to win one
so um that attacking style you know i
hope they continue that you know
throughout the summer because it's been
very sort of entertaining cricket and
you know the last test match at trenton
bridge was probably one of the best
we've seen for a long time
first international test at headingley
since the azi azim
rafiq racism case how much does that
cast a shadow over yorkshire cricket
well i think you know for yorkshire that
that was this was a huge moment for them
to get international cricket and uh they
obviously um
are under extreme sort of financial debt
and they need international you know uh
cricket to be played out headingly and
the timing couldn't be perfect you know
for them for lord patel you know to
hopefully um you know maximize the next
five days in terms of you know financial
you know revenue but also it reminds us
that um you know people talk about
having you know a strong england team
you need a strong yorkshire you know
cricket team as well um the likes of
johnny bears are demonstrating that but
it's disappointing to see you know some
of the players are obviously leaving
yorkshire by end of the season so um you
know hopefully they can turn things
around you know dan goff is doing an
amazing job there but hopefully you know
people can focus on the cricket because
that's what we want to see we want to
see more you know success
uh england doing well and hopefully they
can win this test match and uh you know
we can talk maybe a bit more positive
about um english cricket
nazim's going to be at the game i think
on
the third day i think on
the third day um
what difference do you think it will
make that he is in the crowd
well i think it's important that you
know he is obviously seen at yorkshire
and uh you know that kind of
representation that you know they they
they do uh want him back um at yorkshire
and be some part of uh their sort of you
know
infrastructure uh administration level
and um it's important that he is seen
there because that would encourage you
know the british asians around that uh
you know area to uh get involved with
cricket they feel that they it's an
inclusive sport um but uh going forward
he's also been charged as well as some
of the other sort of players and it's uh
kind of a bit of a
some people think it's a bit of a
hypocrisy they should they should you
know keep it ecb should keep a distance
until all the cases are solved but i
think we need to also create um you know
that the
the camaraderie that that is need
amongst the communities um to feel that
they can go and watch international
cricket so it is important that you know
azim rafiq you know is seen um at the
test matches um so there's people you
know at the wider community kind of
thing well if we do talk about these
kind of diversity racism issues it
doesn't mean that you know we can't go
and watch um a game of cricket or
international cricket at headingley
uh just before i let you go predictions
for the match
well i've got to say three nil you know
bas mccallen and you know ben steaks
have been brilliant um we're gonna have
the likes of jamie overton hopefully
making his test debut and he seems to be
the fastest bowler at the moment uh in
county cricket which is exciting you
know prospect and recently he he sort of
bought a vicious bounce to craig you
know overton so that's exciting to see
um so let's hope uh england can win this
test match and it'll be a very positive
story you know for yorkshire county
cricket club as well
okay good to talk to you our new zealand
director disagrees with you but you
would expect that wouldn't you monty
it's good to talk to you thank you very
much anee for joining us thank you